hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today i'm going to
answer the question how does water
hydrogen bond
meaning i'm going to focus on what
aspect of water
that molecule what's the chemistry
behind it that allows
these forces these hydrogen bonds to
exist
so first let's start by looking at water
i've got a water run up here remember
water is h2o
two hydrogens and oxygen and i'm going
to be talking a lot
about these bonds right here so let me
kind of draw some
arrows right here these bonds
are covalent bonds
and you might be wondering why are we
talking about covalent bonds
we were supposed to be talking about
hydrogen bonds right but really it all
goes back
to these covalent bonds so let's start
now over here
first you have to realize that oxygen is
much more electronegative
than hydrogen
if you haven't learned about
electronegativity yet it's something
that you really do need to try to
understand
it's going to come up in your chemistry
classes electronegativity
is a measure of how strongly
an atom will pull
on electrons in a shared bond
so for example back to our covalent
bonds over here
remember covalent means that the
electrons in those bonds there's two of
them in each of those bonds and they're
shared
so the oxygen and this hydrogen are
sharing these two electrons and the
oxygen and this hydrogen are sharing
these two electrons and because oxygen
is more electronegative than hydrogen it
results in
unequal electron sharing
if you have two atoms that have very
similar electronegativities
um so identical electronegativities like
a bond between two chlorine atoms or
between two hydrogen atoms
or even a bond between two different
atoms that just have very similar
electronegativities like between carbon
and hydrogen for example
those bonds the electrons in those bonds
are shared equally but when you have
a partner like this where oxygen is much
more electronegative
it is going to pull i'm going to
draw some other little kind of arrows
right here in blue
it's going to pull the electrons
in these bonds toward it much more
strongly than the hydrogens are
and so this unequal electron sharing
leads to regions of
partial charge
remember i'll write it right here
electrons
are negatively
charged that's why we write them
like that with an e minus so electrons
are negatively charged
and so when you have these electrons
that are being
pulled more strongly towards that oxygen
it results in partial charge
what i mean by that is
we've got these electrons spending more
time
on this side of the water molecule
they're being pulled towards that oxygen
and they're spending less time on this
side of the molecule
with those hydrogens so that means those
electrons which carry a negative charge
they spend more time kind of up here
that results in
partial negative charge on that oxygen
so even though this is a neutral
molecule there's a partial negative
charge up there
over you know in that region where the
oxygen is
this symbol right here is the greek
letter delta it's a lowercase delta
and that is what we use to indicate the
partial
so it's not a full negative charge just
a partial negative charge
likewise the hydrogens have a partial
positive charge on them and this all
goes back
again to oxygen is so much more
electronegative that it tugs on those
electrons
in the bond even more strongly than the
hydrogen does
and that results in this charge
separation so with a water molecule even
though it's a neutral molecule
you have a part of the water molecule
that's partially negative and a part of
the water molecule
that's partially positive so that's our
partial charge
now the opposite charges
attract that's what opposite charges do
now i'm not talking about
these being attracted to these i'm
talking about between
two different water molecules these
interactions these opposite charges
attract and this is again between two
water molecules
so let me actually draw up some other
water molecules up here now
so i'm going to draw another water
right here while i'm drawing these water
molecules
um i want you to make sure that you
understand
that the covalent bonds
in all of these the covalent bonds that
join the oxygen and the hydrogen
those are what are known as
intramolecular bonds intramolecular
bonds
that means within a molecule so within
between two atoms
of the same molecule that's what these
covalent bonds are
let me draw a couple more right here
and then
on the other hand hydrogen bonds
these hydrogen bonds that i'm going to
write in right here these are the
results
these hydrogen bonds are the result
of attractions between
the partial negatives on one molecule
and the partial positives on another
molecule so let me now go on and write
all of these hydrogens
have a partial positive
and all of these oxygens have two
units of partial negative and again
that's because
they're pulling on
the electrons and two covalent bonds
okay
so now i've got all of my regions of
partial charge
drawn and now i'm going to draw my
hydrogen bonds
okay so again the hydrogen bonds are the
interactions
between the opposite charges the
opposite partial charges
on two different water molecules
so i'm going to draw this as a green
dashed line
i've got one right here between the
partial negative of this
oxygen and the partial positive of this
hydrogen
one right here between the partial
negative of this oxygen and the partial
positive of that hydrogen
one right here between the partial
negative of this oxygen and the partial
positive of this hydrogen
and one right here between the partial
negative of this oxygen and the partial
positive of this hydrogen
so i want you to take away a couple of
things here again the covalent bonds are
intramolecular so within
a molecule between two atoms of the same
molecule
these hydrogen bonds are inter
molecular i'm going to actually add that
to our list down here
of the properties of the hydrogen bonds
so they're intermolecular they are
between atoms of different molecules
um i also want to number them here one
two three
four every water molecule
can hydrogen bond four times can form
four hydrogen bonds at a time
so this one right here we've drawn its
partners you should realize that this
one right here
is also going to hydrogen bond four
times so to this one
and then to three other water molecules
that i haven't drawn
this one hydrogen bonds to this one and
it's a three other hydrogen or
three other water molecules that i
haven't drawn so you can have these
huge networks the these um
these hydrogen bonds they are so
numerous
i'm going to draw a star right there so
numerous and that's because every single
water molecule
can make four of them they also are
strong um and when i say
strong i'm gonna add a caveat to that
and that is they are
strong together an
individual hydrogen bond like this one
right here
you know it can break really easily
and another water molecule
can come in and this one can
reform there and so and then this one
could break again
and then this one could reform and so
the individual hydrogen bonds are not
strong like they're not
nearly as strong as these covalent bonds
but there's so many of them so they're
so numerous
and so when you have billions and
trillions and quadrillions of them
they really add up um and that makes
them very very important
so these hydrogen bonds they allow water
to do so many things they allow water to
be
cohesive and adhesive which is how water
can
move up from the roots up into the stems
up to the leaves
of of a plant or a tree
that that cohesive property is also what
gives us water tension so that something
can float on the surface of water or so
that a little insect can walk across the
surface of water
they're also what enables water to have
such a high specific heat
which means that it can absorb a lot of
energy from the sun during the day
and then release it at night that makes
areas around the coast and around lakes
have those kind of balmy
enjoyable temperatures they don't get as
hot as a desert
during the day and they don't get as
cold as a desert during the night
because all that water is there
um water um enables
life you know and it's because of these
hydrogen bonds that's what i really want
you to realize here
so just sort of to summarize how does
the hydrogen bonding work it all goes
back to the fact that oxygen is more
electronegative
that makes these um these electrons
shared unequally that gives us the
partial charges
and the partial charges are how two
water molecules can interact through the
attraction
of those partial charges to each other
if you're interested in learning
more about how hydrogen bonds and other
bonds things like disulfide bonds ionic
bonds
covalent bonds disulfide bonds of course
being a
subset of covalent bonds you can check
out my video on four levels of protein
structure to learn how these different
kinds of bonds including hydrogen bonds
contribute to
our proteins having the correct strong
structure and therefore being able to
function correctly
you can also check out if you're
interested in
oxygen you can check out my video on
bacteria oxygen requirements to learn
about the different kinds of oxygen
requirements
that different groups of bacteria have
things like air robes anaerobes
facultative anaerobes and so forth
but that's it for today i hope you
enjoyed and thank you for watching
biology professor